نقش الجمال عثر عليه السنه اللي فاتت
وجهود تشكر عليها للامانه وزاره الثقافه
وكمان لما من اهميه الاكتشاف عمل ضجه في
عالم الاثار بشكل عام الدولي فليميز
الموقع ان هذا اقدم اكتشاف
النحت الشكل الجمل الطبيعي
فنحت الجمل كامل على جبل وهم جملين كما
عثر على الادوات اللي ناقشوا فيها الجمل
في نفس الموقع ليش هذا مميزا احنا كاثري
ما نشوف بس هذا نقش هذا مهم لا معناته كان
في جماعه فنانين يدربون النحت كان المجتمع
متطور انه في عنده جماعه مختصه انها تعمل
هذه الفنون وادوات جدا بسيطه فهذا وعمر
النحت من 5000 ل 400
5,700 سنه قبل الميلاد هذا من اهم
الاكتشافات على مستوى دولي في العصر
الحجري الحديث اللي هو عندنا موقعين في
المملكه العربيه السعوديه واقول هذا نقطه
في بحر من الكنوز اللي موجوده عندنا